citizens of the reject Nation it is time
to go to the movies with the Teen Titans
this is one of the rare theatrical one
of these we uh we get to experience I
know it's a momentous occasion going to
the movies we are going to the movies on
TV to the movies people went to the
movies at the movies and you're watching
us watch the movie that people watched
in the movies about going to the movies
dude it's so better layers layers we're
very excited to dive into this one as
ever we want to thank the fine folks at
prepper for prepping this very video to
make it possible we want to thank you
for clicking that subscribe button for
clicking that like button for clicking
that comment button and in that comment
button writing things that you want us
to watch next if you haven't noticed
we're all over the place so let us know
in that little comment daily what you
want us to get after we have not seen
Teen Titans the show
pretty sure there's going to be some
references we don't get you guys already
get mad at me for mispronouncing like
Rochelle Google Rosal ghoul frankly
there's a lot of pronunciations I'm
gonna call him Al from now on but my
point is Al if he's in this I'ma say it
wrong my other point is we haven't seen
Teen Titans there might be references we
missed don't get mad at us we didn't
know we didn't know we didn't see him
also between you and I I want to thank G
fuel Greg didn't even know I was
bringing this they sent me some of these
so the logo they sent me these so G
fuels thank you thank you g fuel I want
to give some love oh my God because uh
this has been keeping me going oh I hear
that that's the sound of energy and
power so
thank you right into the mic I just want
I just wanted to send some G fuel love
uh without further Ado I also want to
thank the patrons who experience not
only front to back beginning to end with
a lot of power and speed thanks did you
feel but they get our energetic resting
watching faces
as we go to the movies so if you want to
see this entirety head on over to
patreon and without further further Ado
let's go to the movies
all right
[Music]
it's theatrical you get Daffy I want
Justice League meets the Looney Tune
um I mean Batman and turtles is the best
thing we've seen it's a market yeah I
would watch Teen Titans meet the Looney
Tunes
it just looks so fun genius no notes oh
look at them caring about comics
that's right
Teen Titans reads some damn Comics
that's correct it's most I've ever liked
a seagull I like that the Teen Titans HQ
has a little golf course now also
they're on an island just just off of
what major city
where are we any town you as Jump City
hey safer than Gotham Plastic Man
Boombox had a stack of Pies oh I respect
that logo there's gonna be so much stuff
to catch all over the first 52 news it
is I the inflated Destroyer
fastest food Flash
[Laughter]
classic povs
yeah up and Adam in clever clever
kick out
dang you're like the Sandman of air very
dense but malleable
dang that's all it takes
I think he should have made a whoopee
cushion no it would have been nice oh oh
is that Raven
like how proud they are just holding the
most cute
[Music]
is that Uncle cyborg is he gonna be like
there is
like big brother cyborg right like 20
something sure
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I do
I don't trust them
Starfire don't fall for it whoa
[Music]
hugged to death
can you just hug this guy
yeah
whoa
[Music]
let's go bees boy
everyone characterization on point
oh
[Music]
well Ace chemical action the dark side
nice opening fart joke yes I mean I'm
only opening four jokes
Justice League
[Music]
I recognize as you know you are the
Guardians of the Galaxy
different superhero universe
this guy don't know who he is oh really
then I think it's time we tell it who he
is
the real heroes taking down the big
yeah oh Teen Titans
of trouble baby Teen Titans Go
Oh morals it's so quiet I love it so
loud to them animals
[Music]
Mr meatball disaster
baby
that was some super small baby whatever
just keep going
oh it's okay Robin
suits
they gotta come in and solve it
oh yeah toughest
and she came all this way you guys want
to hang yeah well we'd love to but we
got to get the Batman's movie premiere
what he's been my dream to have my own
movie well it is important to have
dreams I guess
they did it they did it they did it for
reals has there been a movie about you
you so many and more to come
you know it there was a Green Lantern
movie but we don't we don't talk about
that oh it's okay John it's okay playing
the fool you'll never be seen as real
heroes only as jokes
somebody saved me
yeah who's got you Superman I believe we
have a Premiere to attend Teen Titans go
to the movies oh they're going to the
movies let's go I didn't realize the
title in so many layers it's gonna be a
Teen Titans reaction video oh this is
fantastic Batman again
that is how Affleck would probably
appear at a Ben Affleck Premiere yeah
come on Barry who are you wearing
tonight Plastic Man hey John how are you
oh that's a funny joke so many feelings
about that this Premiere is for
superheroes only for you this fool don't
know who's we is perhaps this will
remind you
man how's we supposed to get in now I
ability to open portals to any feasible
location that's right I always forget
about that
nice
[Music]
[Applause]
man
okay Power Girl
Detective
that's the best one
the original blue beetles
dude no one's gonna miss them
we seem to be drifting in a void of
complete darkness nothing waits for us
here but Madness oh my oh no it's not
heroic is it Gordon yeah I think if it's
records Batman it's plus one I guess not
dead man in the front row you're all
you want a little sneak
sneaker coming this summer
yeah the Burton font Batman it's
happening emerges a hero oh they're
finally going to make a movie about me
[Music]
oh and now it's a show and it's a great
show yeah the origin of Batman's butler
that long title metamorpho
my movie must be slated for next summer
coming next summer the new hero will
line up the night Burton Batman font
it's the car no they did the car before
you bro Batman version of Christine it's
the car that man's greatest Ally that's
me oh the old animated series font I
mean format thank you for making a
utility belt jeezed
he thought the movie was about him oh is
that Patton
ouch
we've got the cool costumes gadgets
I know what's up what are we missing
about an arginess yes doctor man yawn of
Justice
Super Bad Dudes with super
[Music]
super yes
Green Lanterns got sinestra
and the Flash has the rainbow
[Laughter]
oh Deathstroke whoa that shot that
transport likely
[Music]
yes the Justice League will stop you
sorry my pathetic friend but the Justice
League won't be coming that Will Arnett
is Slade Wilson it might the tetronium
crystal the perfect blood device
[Laughter]
[Music]
Deadpool
by the way he should be saying that he's
not me okay because I came out like way
before he did nah DC coming at him look
into the camera and say something
inappropriate
no one can withstand my Powers
an ordinary pencil made of rigid Woods
gonna make it wave can a solid pencil do
this oh
no
an ordinary opposable thumb connected by
flesh
don't do it
no Humanity
look at guys I'm serious look I still
won't do it
no no
there's nothing there hey look see you
later losers give me a call when you
guys learn how to be real superheroes oh
we will he's right we're not real
superheroes
it's okay buddy I love just how much
play Slade Wilson gets in all these
movies like he is like one of the most
recurring villains I mean he was almost
German Giuliana for a whole thing for
the Batman movie it was gonna be the big
bad for Affleck's uh Arkham movie hero
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh geez that was 300.
oh so Robin dreams a lion king yo Robin
come peep this out my man he's got a
bait now sit back relax and enjoy Robin
Young Justice crossed out I would love
someone that's cute boy that lived at
the circus
and things
embarrassing awesome this probably took
a long time it's adorable they worked
all night you
me
get my pants
[Music]
Oh no be careful with the Rainbow Guy
though oh yeah Flash's Big Bad
come on Mystic narwhal narwhals yeah
what the Anne Frank is happening and
Anne wait
Lisa Frank
it was such convicted
that's that's not it I know something's
up
is amazing
[Music]
yeah it's like uh
it's like snorting a Trapper Keeper yeah
the amount of drugs Lisa Frank did to
give us our childhood so appreciate it
Lisa
[Music]
is that Michael Bolton
I think it is yep
oh definitely Michael Bolton if there's
a sack solo
where's papa
Rushmore this beautiful I'm gonna play
this to myself when I'm feeling down
just remember the Michael Bolton tiger
oh yeah
don't tell me this
up bees
it's an updated oh no
I think his dad is a cop
[Laughter]
Cartoon Network like his dad is a cop oh
my God Superman with the mustache on the
Chinese yeah the Big Green ass the
mustache Titans are you ready to be
movie stars yes
[Music]
you don't remember us perhaps this will
remember
how are we supposed to get in uh portal
start with that oh man I love this that
is where the Animaniacs live now
something movie is coming the Animaniacs
or Canon
89 in the Batman uh a lot that's great
detective trip in the case he needs his
own movies
spin-off but every superhero stay at
least time they make one about me and
soundstage must be
Stanley doing my subtle cameo
this is a DC movie oh gee I gotta get
out of here yeah that was actually stand
I'll let the mouse catch you I think it
was yeah that's beautiful oh I love that
stick got a DC cameo this has such good
will it really does it's very warm take
one Batman vs Superman part two and just
have fun with it follow your instincts
what's your mother's name Martha my
mommy's name Martha too
why didn't you say the name what's your
father's name Jonathan mine's a Thomas
she won't just give you a movie you have
to take it now what do you want a movie
oh God it's okay high top films got you
covered would you please make a movie
about me what would that even be it
would be so awesome
it would be the most incredible
superhero movie the world has ever seen
the screens would light up yes
explosions and special effects like tons
and tons of special effects my super
sweet Cape would be special effects yeah
cause it's my movie my movie my
superhero movie It's All About Me yeah
it's all about me yes all the covers
picture my booty up in 3D yes it's
Nightwing that's true it's down the line
in the franchise yeah you billionaire
Standing Tall with adult-sized hands and
gorgeous hair
to be played by John he's ready I am
Robin
boom it would play every time that I
entered a room then I'd say my sweet and
ominous catchphrase
crack an egg on it
cracking egg on it
oh a robin egg I like that they took the
time to make this a real musical no one
wants to watch a movie about a sidekick
I mean the only way I'd even consider it
is if there were no other superheroes I
promise not to keep you in mind for
future projects
Jade Wilson what we have to do is kill
all the other superheroes close but no I
want us to save them from becoming
superheroes in the first place what
what we travel through time and stop
those tragic events from taking place
he's okay with his family dying but not
others see us so Sun the times
[Music]
uh big wheels are always the answer yep
running big wheels on the lot though
that'd be dope oh Libyan terrorists to
sell us plutonium we don't need
plutonium they got the music cue and
everything it's so good
let's go back to the future I mean
oh
powered by radness Fuel the rad
[Laughter]
Jason Todd's first skater I think that's
the voice into cage too engaged
[Music]
damn
what a cut
that's not good at all
someone doing Brando
the planet is collapsing if you want to
save the planet you've got to play the
right music yeah let us show you how
it's done
well
[Music]
this Superman symbol has lights in a
club is something else
the sickest drop in Kryptonian history
oh geez no no there's always butts in DC
animated always butts gotta get those
butts man butts are edgy it's true it's
true they make you laugh
they saved Krypton
[Music]
captures say the World's Greatest
Adventure what character
[Music]
in time they did it they did they saved
it
oh my God
this is oh sheepers no guys no they just
killed him the Aquaman oh the turtles
the Ooze
how did they have the rights to do I
mean I guess that's it's safe
oh Crime Alley stop you can't go down
there that is Crime Alley you dumb dumb
the shortcut through Happy Lane instead
yes where are Martha's pearls oh
there never had to be any back in the
present and there are no more
superheroes
wow oh no
oh hot air balloon I like that this is
freaking rainbow dude oh no Lex
this is saving all the heads the world
has become a horrific Wasteland but are
they still making superhero movies
[Music]
no
movies only suffering yeah I wanted a
t-shirt that says no movie is only
suffering
they've got to read murder
[Music]
that's awesome
yeah they just killed Aquaman
oh
wow wow
[Music]
that was so Savage this is how it's
Slade
if we can make him our arch nemesis then
Jade Wilson will see that we're worthy
of a movie so yeah Titans go
see the secret is they won't have to
Target him yes they'll have to use
nepotism Ah that's the trick in
Hollywood that's a trick so who are Joe
mangiliano's parents I think it's
meganello apologies to Joe manganilla
wow I know I'm Frank and now Joel Manuel
I was so convicted with Anne Frank
thoroughly enjoyed disposing of your
inferior intellects with mine
yes oh my gosh what's that over there
[Music]
oh
oh they've learned what is that on your
shirt right there no if I were you I'm
gonna go in public like that I don't
know how that's possible I'm not even
wearing a shirt
Titans Go yes dang
impressive
[Music]
go
well done Raven nice
[Music]
I'm pretty good with the bow staff how's
it going what up Deadpool
now if they could get a Wade Wilson
appearance
what if they're not calling him dead
Death Stroke because of um the Ben
Affleck movie maybe because they don't
they don't even call them Slade Wilson
just Slade yeah
what is happening
that is my favorite cyborg cyborg yeah
yeah
yes
no one can penetrate our fault nice job
Titans
no
[Music]
he's just ahead
get up
stop milking it saved me let's not make
it a big deal
[Music]
crack an egg on it
it's cool and ominous catchphrase yep I
get away and you foil my next plan in an
even more heroic way that's what happens
in a great superhero movie uh oh don't
listen to a man
middle Hollywood Boulevard got away
they're stronger than I thought not too
strong actually fairly weak compared to
me definitely my cardio is superior
got it gotta stretch man
oh wow it's Jade she wants to see us
tomorrow morning at the studio that's a
trap I don't trust her
guy oh it's the Teen Titans oh wow wow
everyone is talking about you you're on
the list
my man is Jade Wade and drag
wow
that battle with Slade I mean it was
electric you have proven to me that you
are more than a sidekick the Teen Titans
movies
incredible
Miniatures good
[Music]
there's some jokes happening there
there's a reference in there Side
characters like a million Disney movies
so real even the toilet Dark Side
plushies yes I pooped in it do not go in
that bathroom because I just wrecked it
baby
oh no prop toilet I don't know bro look
real to me ah there is nothing quite
like doing the poops in the new bathroom
there is nowhere for the poops to go
try to poop in here everyone poops you
pooped on my set Miss Wilson I am so
sorry it's cool I deal with people like
this all day
Teen
[Applause]
Titans go to the bathroom I'm just
playing Slade in the movie it's me Shia
LaBeouf
oh jeez oh no oh golly
this is aged interestingly this isn't
going to work oh maybe this was a
mistake no no no no no it's not please
just give me a second it's okay they
gave us their Miller a pass
you're gonna be a big star Robin as long
as your team doesn't get into any more
Shenanigans anybody up for some
Shenanigans oh at two cyborg
oh God
it's kind of a good look though
so
oh jeez
that good food
[Music]
well hello Lord
I'm terrible you gotta save me from Gene
Hackman's real estate scheme
[Music]
I'm coming Lois
[Applause]
okay Superman forever Gene Hackman's
real estate scheme
that is the best themed food oh my God
someone please make all of this I hope
they're crafty at the premiere was this
yeah exactly 100 is it crypto or hey it
was Superman's dog's name Ace oh no Aces
Batman's dog crypto yeah you're right
you're right
what no doomsday device let's destroy it
I knew you were goofsters but using Lois
and now this
it's a Bullet Bill we don't have rights
to that by exploiting your other
weakness
oh my God no
no
[Music]
holding a doomsday device doomsday
stands for digitally ordering online
movie streaming directly at you
what
you guys are jokes that's why I won't
make a Teen Titans movie I would make a
a robin movie I know you would never do
it because your friends are too
important to you no
I'll do it no Robin
good luck to you Robin I hope to one day
see your movie I think it will be very
good
a big Hollywood star
yes that trailer oh my God no not the oh
my God he looks like Dexter on picture
day oh it's terrifying just like that
episode of Dexter's Lab
no longer a sidekick that's not me
trick I like how there's no crew just
directing and DP and lighting it's
called it we are about to film the final
scene of your move
don't trust it you just defeated
slay Tower Vault so you can lock away
his evil device along with the pain of
your past Robin the superhero
[Music]
two no no I I'm fine let's finish this
movie and that's what makes you a real
hero
what's your name and address and
birthday recite it to me facial scan
accepted whoa these effects are pretty
impressive oh it's just like our vault
I've designed it with meticulous
attention to detail oh God make it look
real all right
well you were knocked out by our
lighting accident I moved you to the
actual Titan's Tower so you could open
the real Vault for me that would make a
great villain plot
what is that no I don't see anything
there's nothing there made you look no
no
so everything the movie turning me
against my friends it was all just
no it was all part of my master plan
Robin yes I gave all the superheroes
movie deals
I stole valuable pieces of tech from the
cities they once protected I fully
energized ditronium crystals
Crypt your movie with my passengers
for every screen in the entire world and
everyone will be mine to control people
will rob banks for me people will build
monuments insane this shall be your
final scene Magic
no sing a show stopping number I'm a
failure with no friends and tiny little
baby hands oh you're a virgin who can't
drive
the animation is
so disturbs you're so uncomfortable
it's just the details
Titans it's Robin I was wrong I thought
we needed a movie to be real heroes we
were already real heroes cause we were a
team I'm going to Hollywood to set
things right yep that's where you go I'm
sorry I never meant to let you down oh
haha let's go
let's go yes yes let's just say
something Raven our star can't be here
tonight because he has explosives but he
is yes
so without further Ado sit back relax
and enjoy us ruining your play fighting
through explosive diarrhea what a chance
yeah not a goof anymore Jade or should I
say oh
[Music]
no all the heroes no destroy the Teen
Titans
I just want to pause every scene and
like yeah there's so much going on in
every frame we have to destroy that Doom
all right
every Superhero fighting on the water
Brothers lot on your left I think we
lost him
oh no car
oh
way to go Raven
oh my goodness no I had ever thought I
would see that
just like in The Dark Knight
[Music]
that is awesome
that is an amazing
yes yeah
hahaha
hope for the mighty ass this is the
Harry Potter set oh it's a good call
I don't care if it's a DC movie I love
cameos
excelsis I love comic books oh not now
Stanley
[Music]
see opening uh DC logo yeah
justice league dark portal
[Music]
yeah just like in that one that we
watched or like the portal right there
it does work
oh my God no no what are they called
again the heroes of the unknowns they're
staying unknown
[Music]
gets his theme just take a quick peek
it's your movie your movie your
superhero movie It's All About You we
work the animators to the potent for
this hours and hours before the union
the unionized because of this
come on Robin let's take this fool out
[Music]
no Robin stop snap out of it you've
always held me back no man your family
hey boy fight it man
yeah the real one yes it's back
yell just like Bulldogs before the robin
we were all alone
he may not have super powers but he is a
superhero
no
[Music]
yes Titans no he is the back yes he is
oh no a
[Music]
mechan Teen Titans Go Gundam the Warner
Brothers Lots got so much underground
storage I do
mm-hmm
has he had a giant mech suit in the
comics not to my knowledge usually does
his own thing sure
porno portal
whoa
that was weird
[Music]
but we're still going to take you down
with what what are your stupid songs
exactly yes
[Music]
any animal boom hell yeah I'm a kitten
now
[Music]
nice Robin Robin in charge
this song slaps a little bit
Dragon Boy I love the way that he and
Cyborg are able to like
some patio yeah
[Music]
oh
that song was monumentally up
yes it was
free no no no no
poor voyagers are the unknown saved the
world I guess you aren't such goopsters
after all
ah slow clap man I've learned something
important today you don't need to be
super to be a superhero you just need to
be
yourself yep agreed
at least three
[Music]
expanding on that thought
yes why are you still talking I'm simply
trying to highlight the lesson we all
learned no one wants to hear that man
[Music]
[Applause]
but this is not this is my dream
credits credits ask your parents where
babies come from what
hahaha
oh this movie caused a lot of awkward
conversations oh It's gotta be a post
credit scene there's no way there's got
to be something in here yeah it's like
usually we would just start the review
but like I feel like inevitably for a
oh is it working
almost got it oh they need to know we're
still here whoa
can anyone hear us
think we found a way back
whoa the old animation whoa
oh that's cool dang
did that ever become anything
I don't know
because there was no sequel to this
little link to the old animation come
back let's find out that's cool freaking
Michael Bolton too but like Cartoon
Network shut down didn't it effectively
according to this vulture article
um it says that uh you'd think this was
setting up a sequel to Teen Titans go to
the movies uh it's not nor is it
advertising an upcoming gritty Titans
show also about the Teen Titans on uh oh
you remember the DC uh streaming service
oh yes instead it's about another uh
show Teen Titans which used to air on
Cartoon Network before Teen Titans Go
yes still confused of course you are you
see it back in the aunts prior to the
debut of Teen Titans go there were five
scenes of a much more serious cartoon
called Teen Titans the same voice cast
uh years after the cancellation 2006 the
original voice cast was brought back for
this Extremely Goofy and Visually
stylized Teen Titans Go Cartoon previous
uh Teen Titans has been mourned by fans
ever since it's
so I guess also I guess if if this did
well they were gonna bring it back sure
yeah and I mean it could be one of those
things it's just like open-ended of like
hey we know how much people like this
and also
yeah I mean 2018
where are we in the Multiverse where
where are we in the multiversal yeah
thing yeah
um five years ago I don't think titmouse
oh Tim Mouse worked on this nice hell
yeah yeah I'm trying to think because
that feels to me here and now kind of
like one of those multiversal things
like 2018 was Infinity Wars breaking
through you know yeah a lot of things
have done that since that's still fun
though it must have been a great moment
for Teen Titans fans I was gonna say
yeah oh well how are you feeling sir uh
enjoyed it it's definitely not my tone
but I like I was able to put myself into
that tone and have a good time uh it's
it's a fun like very warm experience I
think it introduced you know a lot of
young insta characters that are
delightful in the Teen Titans obviously
are that great uh you know younger
skewing team to get people into sure um
they don't have to be but they they can
be a Gateway as per the first five
seasons being darker and then them going
later
um I definitely like I love the Titans I
always think of the the comic more but
like this is so much fun oh yeah and and
like these characters are so
approachable I know so many people that
know Comics because of the Titans so I
think making a younger skewing movie is
great like that's what you bring
families to so it was a lot of fun yeah
no I agree this was uh at least to me
this was an absolute joy and certainly
this had the the right blend of things I
remember from old Cartoon Network
cartoons that was just that Spirit uh
some of that animation style and
obviously that is part of Teen Titans go
anyway but uh yeah this managed to mix
all of that with you know the joys and
pleasures of a movie and you know the
the sort of meta tone of voice uh again
thinking about you know something like a
Lego Batman like this isn't quite as
hyperkinetic as that is but it is
Michael Bolton yeah sorry I had to check
I feel like Michael Bolton especially
since like The Lonely Island collabs and
stuff let's just get down on the comedy
train
um but yeah yeah like I I uh love you
know this isn't what I'm watching all
the time but you know because I'm a
sophisticated ah yes um but I love this
style I love just this fun and and warm
and bouncy and sort of irreverent
approach to these things and like yeah
you have your your kids stuff like
there's your obligatory fart joke here
or there I feel like especially the
further we've gotten into time in cinema
there's just lost in the credit at least
we know what's in the the challenges
oh it's okay oh that's fun
now that is a post-credits nicely done
appreciate it yeah that was a good
moment
um but yeah this had all the charms I I
love about a cartoon plus all the charms
Teen Titans Go versus Teen Titans there
is another thing okay it looks like they
came back and so that article must be
19. but article has been written before
they must have been written like
immediately as this oh that's awesome
okay cool Teen Titans go see Space Jam
there are so many things oh dang oh wait
wait is this real Teen Titans Go yeah I
mean these are all movies that are real
all right the whole Teen Titans Go move
averse I did not know any of that until
this moment I mean I would be oh I'm
curious about it all and if it's I love
that we were just talking like
theoretically through the whole credits
and everybody everybody watching this
was like yeah there's 10 things that
follow this movie like the Teen Titans
original uh I love that they got to come
back that's really awesome yeah but no
are the same voice actors voicing
like the the series and the comedic
that'd be great that would be a very fun
uh experiment for sure that's great
sorry I didn't realize audience it's all
you know what it's okay we're all human
calls you know what I just don't find
Titans first thank you I appreciate that
behalf of the audience I'm in the comic
medium uh much more than the animated
medium which is why we started this
journey so I could see more of the
animated stuff sure no and and this to
me again yeah it's it's very much in the
spirit of a Saturday morning cartoon but
I thought it had enough of that sort of
knowing uh you know genre ribbing uh
that sort of loving but uh meta you know
irreverent genre ribbing and it's enough
of a movie to feel like an actual movie
it it doesn't feel like eh you know this
is this you kind of could have plopped
this on TV like this was really charming
and consistent and so many great little
background details and like little
surprise characters popping up and and
the fact that yeah they what I
appreciated too because there was a
Space Jam a new Legacy uh screen that
HBO is uh propped in front of us and
it's funny because I'm looking at this
and I was just listening to somebody
rant about me I was listening to the
releasing the YMS rant about Space Jam a
new Legacy and part of what he was
talking about was that you know it's all
Warner Brothers stuff which again is
part of the point but if you look at the
original Space Jam they would pull stuff
from like outside of there yeah and I
appreciate this even though it did a
bunch of stuff with the DC stable and
Warner Brothers in general it wasn't
only doing that and it was doing like a
bunch of like Marvel knots Stan Lee like
it it I think it helps when you're doing
like a big meta mashup and you're
borrowing so now it feels like a Pure
commercial yeah yeah it's like if you're
Reaching Across the aisle some of the
time and and you know making the F that
suggests that you had to make us some
kind of concerted effort to include this
and I think those are choices that are
strong and that help you know make
something like this feel special yeah
rather than just a volley of like hey we
have the rights to this so this is
technically a commercial for our catalog
yeah you know which is definitely a
Space Jam felt like yeah and I loved the
just meta Narrative of Robin wants his
movie and I mean Robin in live action
Cinema has been such a thing over time
and so like it made for to me like the
right meta-narrative and then to have it
be that the movies are sort of what
they're using to you know pull one over
the world yeah warp the world and
brainwash all the other superheroes and
stuff like that you know like I thought
they did a really fun and nice job and
it played off of things that we've seen
in the past like I started to think of
some of the DC AMU Teen Titans movies
that we saw and at least uh at least the
first one of those was like pretty high
on both of our lists yeah yeah we like
first one yeah and the other one that we
didn't like as much has uh as Slade
Wilson in like a creepy relationship
with Terror yeah so uh so so having
Slade Slade slave having him be the the
arch nemesis like is that true to the
comics is he there kind of guy
Deathstroke is kind of the big bad in a
lot of different facets and it's so much
play well because he's like he's he's
like well he's like nipples he's a very
interested character that's got like
awesome weapons and looks really cool
and he's snarky and fun and I mean I
really wanted that Joe mangionello take
and I really thought that like the
Batman movie that Ben Affleck wanted to
make was apparently incredible and then
that was the big bad and we were so
close but I think there was just so many
cooks in the kitchen there were so many
moving Parts like at points like
Deathstroke was going to be in multiple
things we only got that one Cameo I
think in a post-credit scene sure so it
just but Deathstroke's a huge huge part
of the DC Universe he's he's a big bad
okay um but yeah I thought this did a
really good job playing with narrative
it definitely felt like a movie versus a
show it didn't feel like three episodes
of the show it felt like a movie
um I do think they did a good job making
it uh approachable for young and old
there were definitely more adult jokes
to tie into the young even though it's a
very young tone I loved some of the the
layers in there the Easter eggs were a
plenty which I'm sure the animators had
a great time making sure there was a lot
to bite into
um yeah it's just I I don't generally
watch a younger she's queuing stuff so
I'm I'm I had a harder time connecting
uh just because I haven't watched you
know the Cartoon Network era stuff in in
years and years uh but I love that this
exists so like when I inevitably have
kids they'll have something to be like
this is like I I won't show a
five-year-old the Batman
that's when they're sevens
yes
I've got something to show no but I do
think it's really good to have a like a
Gateway for kids to get into and I think
this is the perfect way to show them
something a little longer good attention
span Builder good way to show them like
the difference in movies and TV good way
to introduce a lot of characters I think
it's important for these things to exist
uh and I also think it's important to
know
even if it's not how you see uh you know
the medium there are versions of all
these things and I say that about like
you know multiverses but also even tones
and things so I think the Teen Titans
are a very Universal approachable team
and this shows that yeah no 100 and uh
and I feel like with this too it's a
nice kind of bridge because yeah it's
something the kids can easily enjoy but
it's also something that parents if
you're I imagine if you were a parent
and you're not already versed in comics
or something and you had to watch this
this would probably be kind of fun for
you too and this would play on stuff
that you've probably at least been
slightly aware of in pop culture even if
you're not grabbing all the Easter eggs
and I think recently I expressed to it
because I'm always sitting here being
like give me a romance but also I think
it's something we were watching my
Gaslight and I was like there was that
musical number and I was like I want one
of these to be a musical and here we are
that was our full-on musical yeah and
like you know obviously again it's
pitched more towards kids you literally
have a Disney animation you know like
riff in the middle name is as a Gotham
movie though I love we're getting a full
adult musical comic might be a little
that's yeah yeah he's like I don't know
if we'll ever see that I hope we do but
it's called Uh the Folly of two that
comes out next year you know what though
I think it's true yeah Oscar winner uh
singer for Walk the Line and uh Miss
Lady Gaga yeah I mean the fact that I
love that I never would have thought of
the joker as a musical and then they
cast someone who played someone that got
a musical Oscar for a biopic and then
cast a an actually great like New York
voiced woman that is a talented singer
like it feels like everything conspired
to make that sequel Musical and it's
gonna piss off all the Bros that like
emboldened by the first one like that is
such a perfect Faded Line for usual
sequel I'm so excited oh 100 I'm like
super stoked for Joker too yeah and and
yeah I'm excited to Crest into the world
of serious superhero musicals with a
Twist I'm sure is Joker but like this
was a nice step because yeah it is like
a family joint so it makes sense to have
it be a musical and even though you know
it's it they're rapping and stuff and
that's a whole Trope unto itself of like
cartoon characters be rapping yeah like
the songs were pretty decent like they
were pretty catchy pretty good like for
what this is I feel like the songs could
be way more forgettable or way more just
sort of like ah you know whatever yeah
um and I thought they did a nice job I
like that the song came there it was a
reprise came back and was part of the
key to solving you know to to
vanquishing Slade's plan has
acknowledged by Slade yeah and uh yeah I
just thought this tied together really
nicely uh yeah and much love to Lisa
Frank yes
both doing a lot for young lives
at least four times imagine if Anne
Frank's diary was contained in a Lisa
Frank
imagine if they reimagined Anne Frank's
diary and Lisa Frank imagery no the
problem is give it give cap if Capital
if our current landscape doesn't just
crumble into the Earth because people
don't read anymore the only way you're
gonna get something to read and Riggs
diary in today's school system and get
Elisa Franken it's a yeah yeah it's a
it's a Kindle with Elisa Frank like flap
on it well I'm picturing like dolphins
as Nazi soldiers I'm picturing like this
thing is psychedelically colored it is
intense Lisa Frank the estate of Lisa
Frank whoever you are please do not
adapt it for next time
don't don't do that yeah I think I think
we found the line yeah there it is there
it is but yeah I love the Lisa Frank
Love uh and that was absurd and then
they killed the tiger which was such a
fun weird like fourth wall like what's
real yeah what's real what's fantasy
you've got the the the the the
unknown dudes yeah it's floating out
there in nowhere in the credits land
like uh and and I and I really liked the
recontextualization of we've seen
different iterations of like who leads
the team and who's more of an adult
versus who's more of a kid and I thought
having them all be kind of
not specifically defined as of this
movie but you know it seems like they're
pretty all close together you know yeah
it makes it kind of fun like you know
we've seen the take where it's like oh
Starfire and and uh Nightwing are kind
of like watching over everybody and
there's like Uncle cyborg in this case
they're all teens yeah it's here they're
all together they're all their own
little portal joke also very good that's
another commentary on the super her
culture yeah that was some fun in there
that was that was good always take and
we got a real Nick Cage we did Superman
we did I was so thrilled it was
beautiful so thrilled by that well that
I believe is gonna do it for Teen Titans
go to the movies even the title itself
has layers which I appreciate very much
that was very fun yeah uh yeah that is
gonna do it let us know in the comments
below what you want us to get into next
uh we also have been watching Superman
and uh I've been enjoying that very much
I think by the time this airs we will
have finished season one because it will
have aired or thereabouts close to it
we're gonna try to get on that one
quickly so we'll be diving into that uh
let us know what else you want us to get
into thank you very much for being here
we will see you for the next one much
love reject Nation have a good one